And then the worst snake of all his
malevolence,
and that's I think that's technically
correct because one of the things that
you view,
for example,
when you're looking at posttraumatic
stress disorder,
is that it's almost always the case that
someone who suffers from post traumatic
stress disorder,
which you might think of as a real real
life re incarnation of the fall,
is that people encounter something
malevolent and it breaks them because
it's the worst thing to understand.
It's like suffering is one thing,
man,
that's,
that's bad enough.
Vulnerability and suffering,
that's bad enough,
but to encounter someone who wishes that
upon you and will work to bring it
about,
that's a whole different category of
horrible,
especially when it also reflect
something back to you about yourself.
Because if someone else can do that to
you and they're human,
that means that you partake of the same
essence.
Strangely enough,
that's actually the cure to some degree,
to posttraumatic stress disorder is like
if you've been victimized,
you're naive and you've been victimized.
The way out of that is to no longer be
naive and to no longer be victimized,
and that means that you.
You see this reflected in the Harry
Potter idea,
for example,
that the reason that Harry Potter can
withstand voldemort is because he's got
a piece of a already been touched by it
and the way that you.
The way that you keep the psychopaths at
bay is to develop the inner psychopaths
so that you know when,
when you see what right and then,
but that's a voluntary thing.
It's,
it's so.
It's like a.
it's like a a set of tools that you have
at your disposal which has full
knowledge of evil and that does.
Nina said,
if you look into an abyss for too long,
you risk having the abyss gaze back into
you.
Right?
The idea is that if you look at
something monstrous,
you have a tendency to turn into a
monster and people are often very afraid
of looking at monsters.
Things exactly for that reason,
and then the question is,
well,
should you turn into a monster?
And the answer to that is yes,
you should,
but you should do it voluntarily and not
accidentally,
and you should do it with the good in
mind rather than falling prey to it by
possession essentially,
because that's the alternative.
And how does it possess you?
That's easy.
You're suffering makes you better.
Your bitterness makes you resentful,
you're resentful,
mate means meat,
makes you vengeful.
And once you're on that road,
you go down that a little bit farther,
man,
while you end up fantasizing in your
basement about shooting up the local
high school and then killing yourself,
right?
Because that's sort of the ultimate end
of that line of pathological reasoning.
Beings should be eradicated because of
its intrinsic evil.
And I'm exactly the person to do it and
I'll cap it off with an indication of my
own lack of worth just to hammer the
point home.
Right?
And if I can garner a little post post
post you miss fame along the way,
well that'll satisfy my primordial
primate dominance hierarchy,
a imaginings to at least in fantasy.
So you know,
it's the full package if you want to go
down that route.
And of course people don't like to think
about that sort of thing and it's no
bloody wonder,
but without the capability for mayhem,
Europe,
you're,
you're a potential victim to mayhem,
so you need your sword.
It should be sheath,
but you need to have it and it's very
frequently the case.
If you treat someone with posttraumatic
stress disorder,
the.
There's two things you have to do.
You have to help them develop a very
articulated philosophy of evil because
otherwise their brain bothers him over
and over and over.
Why?
Why were you so deal with naive?
How did you become victimized?
Why were you such as soccer?
These are good questions.
You don't want to have that happen to
you again.
You don't want to be exploited twice.
Okay?
So your eyes have to open up.
We know the price of that from the
Egyptian myth,
right?
You come into contact with Seth,
what happens?
Even if you're a god,
you lose it.
I,
it's no joke,
man.
It's no joke.
And then the cure for that is the
movement down into the underworld and
the revitalization of the father.
That's the identification with the
forest that created culture,
right,
and that then there's you and that
together.
Then you can withstand malevolence.
Maybe you can withstand tragedy and
malevolence and then that's the whole
secret,
right?
Because that's what you want in life.
You need to be able to withstand tragedy
and you need to be able to withstand
malevolence because those are the forces
that are always working against you,
and so it's.
This is associated with the union idea
of incorporation of the shadow,
right?
You have to be.
We know this God,
we know how predators work with regards
to children.
Even if you're a pedophilic Predator and
you're looking at a landscape of
children,
the child that you're going to go after
is the one that's timid and won't fight
back.
You've picked your victim and predatory
people in general are exactly like that
man there because they're predators.
They're not going to attack someone
who's who's going to fight back.
In fact,
the issue is likely not to even come up.
They're going to be looking for someone
one way or another that cannot
conceptualize what they are and then
perfect.
It's,
it's open season and it's open season,
and so if you're treating someone with
posttraumatic stress disorder,
first they need an introduction to the
philosophy of malevolence and second,
they have to learn to become dangerous
because that's the only way out.
What's the alternative?
They get these recurrent thoughts about
their vulnerability in the face of
malevolence and their own naive nutty
because by definition,
if someone psychopathic has exploited
you,
you're too naive.
It's.
It's a definitional issue.
You can say,
well,
that's no fault of mine.
How the hell could I be prepared?
Fair enough,
man.
Perfectly reasonable objection doesn't
solve your problem because it's an.
It's an eternal problem.